ah yeah it's the bee sting king in the
Rat King
[Music]
it's up man what's up not much
your Pedialyte distracting grown men
don't drink Pedialyte I don't know no
one told you that growing up anybody
could drink this nope not true
found the children's sex really yeah and
if you dress like that you didn't have
proms
where I'm from what are you talking
about this is a nice outfit I think well
let's give enough to rip my drip already
yeah let's get right into it
fine this is strawberry flavor you had
this is that strawberry yeah so is that
children's summer strawberry Oh kids can
drink it pedia do you can't be drinking
Pedialyte did you look at ropes aren't
you you guys can frickin do shots
together have fun bro yeah you don't
have any kids bro so it's very strange
you came in with that you know like it's
nothing to put in another kind of bottle
so just think be less creepy with it you
know I'm saying I don't like how you
flaunting around the studio I'm not
ashamed of it I guess it is weird I
guess cuz uh I'd look like seven empty
bottles in the backseat you like the
grape is good that drip drip sizzurp
this is Steele's outfit here you look
like you look like Captain Planet side
piece you know how when you're gay guys
start freaking looking like each other
when they hang out too much that's what
you look like you look you're a captain
plant gets up the exact same haircut
first of all exact same haircut you look
like you see the set these iam okay you
get that donator the P like you uh you
look like that pedialite brothers in my
best morning
yeah that's both of us dude and I know
what you look like you look like a Boy
Scout leader who carries [ __ ] granola
in his pants and sucks the boys off
behind the trees what why couldn't I
just have a good snack for the kids man
understand here's the haircut bro you
don't have a haircut like then just a
delicious snack what see everybody knows
that well you know how many squirrels
come after this cut that's ready rat
dude you don't you look like you look
like before your boys about to shoot the
biggest special in his life you sent him
the best message of all time and it made
my day oh I appreciate a man that
I was nervous as [ __ ] really super
nervous and he sent me out message and
really came through as I appreciate you
thanks [ __ ] touch me you don't
[ __ ] touch me ever dude go on to me
congratulations man
thanks man ass your video was really
cool well thank you sweetie you just say
man I'm proud of you
thanks brother it's hard to get work
sometimes out here and you know you're
probably the first guy with CT to ever
shoot at a state of a special number one
yeah number one first guy ever to have
his own comedy special show time you
idiot or call CT the brain damage to the
brain damage or just yeah I won with it
just the haunt or with a question mark I
was born within you earned it the nature
versus nurture brain damaged or you just
born like this and I freakin earned mine
man do you no wonder he might be a
scientist or so I know I might be you a
must but not if I can eat lon mustard
let's bring this guy's trip up man dude
look at that swaggy swaggy
Wow ripped rip those pants are what kind
of cut is that boot cut you cut you're
dressed like a deaf person dude he's a
mute cut pants well no and there's baby
blue shoes nothing good you want to you
wanted us you should drink Pedialyte if
you were in that I mean those are hey I
just had a boy I just had twin boys I
just had quadruplet boys that is a
severe baby blue as you can get man dude
those are the Travis Scott's cactus you
better step your game up
and don't ABS Ravis Scott sounds like a
four-year-old is that somebody's name
it's a rapper's name oh wow where's the
real rapper's murder you know Larry
murder frickin you know Larry murder
yeah [ __ ] Archibald
you know killer you know Master P Bert
yeah mystical Barry and [ __ ]
Johnson you know where the real rappers
at Travis Scott and principal Ernest
yeah yeah they're not artists to murder
and precedent but at least they were
real Travis Scott isn't even Sam his
girls uh Kylie Jenner it is dude
everybody calls Holly Jenner
okay if not if your wife that's true and
Kylie Jenner should count as reparations
dude isn't that kind of reparations
don't the Jenners count come on I think
we're even
I think rip my trip first of all you
wearing that uh let's get Jocko we'll
ink on the line and let him know that
you're wearing fake army here pick up
chicks even there's only dudes in the
office
ah wow you take you into that fake valor
you'll get you into boot camp at
footlocker bro you look like you look
like somebody gargle their own balls and
then just [ __ ] I'm a swallow yeah
well that's who you are and then you put
clothes on top of it so oh your drip is
ripped but I'm happy about your comedy
best don't [ __ ] touch don't touch me
dude do we get some good yeah my
sessions submissions first one ideally
we want to start ripping other people
sites just meet there damn look at this
swaggy feller Alex fruition looks like
you straight up
looks like you straight off mister Big
Pun and the terror squads Oregons swag
yeah it looks like Fat Joe mmm yeah a
little bit doesn't he yeah he looks like
he like hey what's that jacket made out
of boiled leopard no boiled Python then
a pump full of freakin fat did he well
he's clearly at the Grove so that's in
Los Angeles cuz I know exactly where
he's at now that coat is way too thick
for LA really oh dude illusion where
that looks go he's that water cold maybe
he was in the water the breeze off the
mountain you say yeah yeah maybe the
breeze coming out that fountain could be
kind of chilly
oh yes the swaggy J's on - I'm not mad
at this man style now look you know what
he looks like me if I once I hit a bad
break that's what's gonna happen oh yeah
he definitely looks like you if you are
you know he looks like you maybe if you
had taken a little better care of
yourself probably he looks like he makes
the meanest calzone in the world oh
goody he looks like he has the best
bratwurst in all the land
oh it looks like he could fall asleep
with bread under one arm
and marinara and the owner on the other
and wake up with a calzone in his
bellybutton
full body chef like a chef chef body Rd
bro this dude of this policy with
ingredients all over his body and wake
up with a Crim relay on his dick chef
swaggy D what else we got shoutout to
that dude why he doesn't fit anything in
Topshop Oh Juan Gonzalez wine Gonzalez
he looks like y'all a salsa dancer the
Guerlain [ __ ] that's what he looks
like
dude does he look like that you don't
think three limited arms and I say that
because I have limited are youdo you
both have that t-rex via I don't have
that real
you know I'll hug you but I'm not gonna
my hands aren't gonna touch behind your
back kind of vibe you know you're not
gonna beer hug anybody I'm not gonna
bear hug anybody but I'll [ __ ]
raccoon hug any [ __ ] in the
joint yeah your Posse hug somebody yeah
you got to throw that Rack Attack on him
now this guy definitely looks like he he
looks like a guy in Charleston that
sells used cars I feel like yeah he
looks like he has those fake Cuban
cigars in his back looks like he looks
like he attempts to speak Spanish but
can't you know he has an app on his
phone and it's not working out he's
trying to pick up chicks it's just not
going well for him yeah he definitely
seems like he like maybe he grows
papayas or something in his front yard
or he'll try to throw that swagger on
every like the case Adela when it's nice
that's what I do
yeah man that guy but you know what I'll
say this he looks like a nice man he
looks like he probably you know went to
college and they have a mirror in his
house that's nice some people don't have
that that is a nice mirror given in the
hardwood floors I'm not mad at those do
poor people one thing do not have nice
mirrors that's whatever that's not Lisa
gonna spend on you just ask somebody
else the house what you look like and
they be like you look like [ __ ] and
you're like cool all right I'll see you
yeah that was the drill but he
definitely looks like a disc jockey I
think he looks like a disc jockey on
like a plantation dude he looks like he
definitely and I don't know if he you
know has ever had any s la ves
but somebody in his family has oh wow
hey all right okay I see we were going
with that oh it's crying maybe a little
bit of a vibe there huh I feel it I mean
I was more surprised it took a while
spelling bees weren't my forte getting
stung by bees was dude he looked he
looks like he owns one of those uh those
frickin smoke shops that's what he looks
like he looks like he owns one of those
who could joints and tries to talk to
the girls in Spanish and it's not going
yeah so he dressed like a Spanish fella
yeah he's in Miami clearly yeah this
guy's in Miami or he just has the air he
lives in like Ohio maybe Columbus and
does the heat cranked up and like a nice
guy yeah shout out to that dude keeping
it swag even in freakin Ohio man yeah
all right the next one is sarena beer
damn damn girl that's that Freddy
Krueger stylist she didn't say my dreams
bro she doesn't that Freddy Krueger
style yes dream do your animal you feel
me your daughter me or say what does
that mean cat do you know should do cat
come on dude she's not Spanish you know
Spanish well what is the same because
she's Asian
right now this America better get you
learn Spanish fast dude you're right
you're right yogi assume in honor I see
that even on her face big something
adult man he a nice guy
is that Angelina Jolie yeah is that a
model Wow when what she wants to rip
anything to rip but that dress off just
kidding just kidding and I will testify
yes you are witness where I said just
kidding yeah pan down a little bit oh
[ __ ] oh she's a redhead bro
she got that louis c.k she does your
louis c.k yeah wow yeah look at those
yeah I'm Ching going ultra slow down oh
you know the only thing that bad leg now
she has a bad leg so she's a little
bowlegged and it goes in so that's pride
in her that's gonna tweak that ACL on
the left there you know I'm saying yeah
well she has one of her feet the right
and this is look this happens to like
probably one out of maybe 60 or 70
thousand children but their foot does a
full right turn in the other direction
yeah we call it the Forrest Gump if she
practice so she just rolls with it
her boots are she gets the Andy Dufresne
z' they're busted up you know sexy yeah
where you shine them you know it's
whatever I'm cool with the boots
oh dude I would definitely say what naio
with that girl you know what I'm saying
bro yeah I call through some chipper
luncheon I'm one of her legs and right
Brooks was here right up near of a gene
you feel me
yeah I'll hug girl I got real hit her
yeah now does she
redhead bro he's got a set of lips on
her - does she who knows first of all
this is very pixelated yeah it looks
like it's from the 90s yeah but she
looks like she's from the future she had
died me done she definitely she's a dime
she was a dime in the 90s I bet she's
about eight cents right now though yeah
she's at eight out of ten because
there's a little bit pixelated but with
that set man she seemed like a nice
young lady she looks like she probably
grew up somewhere and they had a lot of
different you know items in the house to
keep each other healthy good skincare
fresh water she looks like she works at
forever 21 yeah I yes dude really what
are you doing it for over 21 I just roll
by it it should not go by it dressed
like that do not do that whatever bro
don't make me drink my Pedialyte what
else we got she's a dime that's it for
my trip that's what it means forever - I
thought it meant forever - or one
forever - or one so two for one deal nah
man maybe where you're from oh yeah most
places it's forever 21 do you know
what's funny when I was dumb you can
only be 21 and under - shopping really
yep huh
you know we used to go to the mall and
camp out we'd take a tent with your camp
out and slide only can't we stay it we'd
go to the mall and then get out of the
mall camp out overnight outside and then
go back in them all the next day oh wow
looking for deals or what try to get in
there trying to get that [ __ ]
fresh-baked cookies emissions beer get
that early hitter out of miss fields but
yeah just being in there we just love
being in the mall dude they had all kind
of stuff umbrellas everything I'm gonna
get lost in the outdoor world you ever
been like dicks in the mall the giant
dick oh yeah it's crazy yeah you could
sleep in there yeah I don't lie to sleep
in them you have to sleep outside but we
saw this we just had like the best thing
we had was a like journeys or something
one of those stores oh yeah that is like
the journeys turn into journeys and
Spencer's the same thing I think it yeah
used to be Spencer's maybe now
journeys but we had spencer's that's
what we had yeah real Spencer's you go
in there and they had like a lava
language no one ever bought anything no
stole something or just a little walk
yes no you never saw anyone with the
actual receipt yes same thing with
sharper image yeah I don't touch
everything I don't know one single
person my entire life I ever bought
anything yeah it's like hey massage
chair was 30 G's I'm 14 did we were
always still eliminating this [ __ ]
massage they had the weirdest I like who
wants a baby diaper that sort poins
you know wish Oh little Lawrence is
awake and guess what we got $3 and dimes
you know piece of [ __ ] let's move on
weird [ __ ] what do we got now guys our
new king of sting yeah you know your
buttons are you good for king of C we
need them hit us it's time for King
it'll sting it DJ brown brown brown book
Brown DJ big brown and your favorite
stepmom deal deal with the Rat King barn
[Music]
[Applause]
all right first one's from Michael huff
you look like you just got fired the rag
guys doing shut out the neck and chin
the back don't work names Michael Huff
I'm a truck driver so I can't really say
I can replicate so I rep all of the US
of A that's what I'm from serial killer
and yeah candor sting and I got for you
guys today
spinners spinning wimps please trying to
see if I could put some of my truck give
everybody a breeze let me know I see out
there is referring to spinners to girls
cuz he's jacking off in that truck all
across America isn't bro why are you
thinking about that man he seems like a
nice guy I was just trying to get
potatoes too from [ __ ] from Idaho
here's a picture of spin oh damn you
know this is kind of spin she's talk Oh
dope this guy's awesome he looks like
it's part of lenny kravitz crew dressed
like that
yam help dude hell yeah the spinners now
late I'd say late 90s early 2000s Nelly
made them super hot yeah people had
spinners Sprewell's to me free Wells bro
yeah but now you get them not great bro
however on your truck it's pretty swaggy
oh I think if you got that big you know
that Cruiser I mean that dude me when
you basically when you're in an
18-wheeler whatever there are 19 wheeler
those things are amazing bro I mean you
could [ __ ] hit somebody a hitchhiker
you don't even feel it
we carry 70,000 people yeah no one cares
Oh Road trafficking human trafficking
those things are easy yeah bro
trafficking bro and get rid of these
shady crops if you're you know driving
around you know lemons or squirrels
squirrels yeah which is really tough
there's no way could convince how many
squirrels to get into a bag of a truck
just put nuts in them but I'll say this
that you could get a good product
medical devices yeah like he's saying
Legos Lego
snow that's not a oh how about meat like
okay like filets get me dude say yeah
give me that Salmonella bad boy [ __ ]
running dirty weed all around the
18-wheeler me baby through that
18-wheeler me oh yeah bro how many I bet
that guy's chicks all over they put a
thriving and swipe it on ten oh let's
dude [ __ ] all over the land spreading
his seed in every city with them lot
lizards oh it's actually a pretty good
gig you know how like a lot of
professional athletes have groupies
truck drivers has lot lizard it's
Michael Huff man yeah bro so Michael
Huff you just he just pulls into there
to refresh you know and get a quick nap
before youth on the road and then this
lot lizard just jumps into the truck and
sucks the boys off goes to the next
truck everyone your story somebody gets
me and if it's like about Christmas or
anything man you need to [ __ ] get
your act together yeah you know I need
to see the guy you're seeing
okay I need you're talking to somebody
but that's a lot lizard bro that's life
you ever seen true life I'm a lot lizard
no oh and their mouths are just so ashy
and lightly and just inflamed from
sucking trucks every cog yeah happens
bro and it would be tough to to blow
somebody's just been dry
all day that's you talking about the
sticky dick that truck driver dick oh
it's like Eva [ __ ] Slim Jim
yeah good I would pull the whole company
back home that would be a how could you
bro you know if I was a truck driver I'd
walk in I'd get a [ __ ] full coca-cola
Slurpee a slim jim go back to my truck
how will them lot was it come in and
then just Slurpee Slim Jim dick every
state bro brother every state and then
just pick out the pink starburst that
should be the national anthem what she
just said
then what yeah when I come haha dude
you're right dude they're living alive
then we think about it you're gonna they
figured it out man you could be one of
the top 60 or 70 truck drivers I'll bet
Michael off I like you you keep it
strolling out there with them spinners
now if you get them big spenders I would
love to see you get something like they
have on those windmills where the
spinners create enough electricity to
keep that truck going that's smart at
least keep a lava lamp going up in the
front yeah that's smart
you know he's smart and if you could
actually ejaculate into that [ __ ]
lava lamp bro you could add more lava I
mean think about it a bunch of sperm
worm spinning around in your lava lamp
daddy now we're talking dude yeah I like
this like sea monkeys yeah yeah but see
monkey lava lamp dude why don't they
make a lava lamp for boys oh Jesus adult
men's bedside table yeah eating jizz in
and then it [ __ ] lives in there yeah
like sea monkeys then you feed them yeah
crackers no no yeah all right wha but
definitely say King spinners on your
18-wheeler so now King it man nice
alright next one's from Ethan Ludwig
what's up the--when Brendon it's your
boy here oh he's the lead singer i sobre
neighbor brothers you play that game you
really brown neighbor brown neighbor
won't you do me a favor only think about
brown neighbor
neighbor won't you do me a favor take
that brown and flush it down take that
brown and flush it down and you hit on
the wall really yeah and you guys like
over that never really never because
where I'm from you keep your face
forward and you don't open your stupid
mouth but if you drop you drop the
Browns off to the Super Ball and you get
out of there bro you get the [ __ ] out of
it well you're limited obviously come
from a limited existence and what I'm
saying yeah you would do brown neighbor
brown neighbor won't you do me a favor
that part was the take that brand and
flush it down send it down a sewage can
and you'd hit the wall oh wow you know
if you tap your foot
game on yeah yeah like you tap it under
you're gonna get something that you
don't want what you might I don't know
but it's not my thing
I don't then why are you telling people
how to do it and sending up the vibe
dude here's what I'm saying is this I'm
gonna say big sting it do not talk to
your neighbor while you're dropping
loads
dude one time a big black guy was in the
stall next to me and he kept beating the
wall he's like give me that Curtis it
flows dawg
really yeah and I got so scared there's
a Shaquille O'Neal I have no idea
brothers [ __ ] but you were seal but you
were scared huh you were scared what's
the smell like [ __ ] and he got really I
think it was but I think it was him man
damn he punked you you did flush that
[ __ ] you don't want it cuz you're still
on the thing on the cold water gets on
your ass dude Joe Rogan has one of them
toilets that shoots water in your booty
oh oh really if you take a [ __ ]
not for me not for me really not for me
now it's like me Sea World I guess you
get those at SeaWorld yeah you can for
the Dolphins but I didn't I used in it
was a it was a it was a mess my Bundy's
were wet my jeans got wet I was actually
dirtier I don't know what I'm doing
yeah we're you using it to get to to
hydrate yourself after a basketball game
dude I thought is a water fountain
there's just a nice water up I don't
know different times man I'm gonna
definitely say sting [ __ ] and
talking to anybody because I'm an
American and that's very very unamerican
dude
so you're saying sting it big sting okay
I'm knocking I'm taking shits I don't
like my friends like hey man no no no no
dude I'll talk to you I get out I'm
doing working it I gotta focus this yeah
focus yeah one end of my body
at a time you know eating my mouth
closing my butts open or visitors what
I'm singing is this dude I think these
days sitting on the [ __ ] and
listening to somebody is probably one of
the most trusted ways to get news in
America so no it's the truth
yeah I mean it could be it's just as
good as anything else so I say it's a
trusted news source [ __ ] to [ __ ]
wall-to-wall communication you're right
there
you know I say keep the rumor mill
afloat and just don't forget to flush
Braun when I come from neighbor now that
where I come from so well oh I said it's
King it you're King in it yeah yeah I
said King it
I say stating it alright next one is no
O'Connor man no Rat King and the bee
sting gang gang baby bunk beds buzz buzz
baby kangaroo sting it girls with nose
rings
I don't think of that weird but the ones
that make them look like a ball freaked
me out bro
preach louis c.k here's the thing dude
that I agree with homeboy the one here
yup daddy issues the one on the side we
gonna Sizzla I love the one on the side
I think that's so sexy even a fat girl
can do that like damn that [ __ ] sexist
yeah they put that little one that
little cute one on the side oh yeah look
like RiRi oh yeah well you know what
he's gonna sizzle they've been out of
business about seven years they're just
gonna be driving around with a woman in
your car no you'd be surprised
do you be surprised you can see they're
still around really your scissors are
around the other thing we're like on the
black market
yeah that's that truck driver who also
was wearing a wig we didn't bring that
up about the guy okay gay was bro that's
Lenny Kravitz like he's a damn
good-looking dude he's the most stylish
truck driver I've ever seen also is he
on a set why is there black curtains
behind them you know why cuz he's diggin
down all the lizards in the back look at
thanking him down with hatchets bro
most people who drive around across the
country [ __ ] people are our killers
no you got that wrong brother oh my bad
dude man they drop off nice quality
goods and then they spread their seeds
amongst the town that's true dude when
you come to think of it a lot of them
kids are on America just probably come
from truck drivers the majority yeah
that's crazy
I go back to the
boy these nuts got to be in Utah by
morning honey I'm out yeah okay um gang
gang man I love that beer dude that is
that beard that it's like another couple
inches and I'm moving out of the house
or I'm taking my whole family into that
wait you know yeah you he looks like the
lead singer of Godsmack yeah yeah and he
looks like the Lord touched him too bro
man is truly beautiful got beautiful
blue eyes on him it's healthy skin to
moisturize he's safe team jacket on it
looks like he's working for this city
probably not getting paid cuz they're on
strike right now which is pry way it's
time to send this welcome for the City
of Hope brother he probably cures cancer
dude what are we gonna learn from this
guy we learned that the bull ring is
disgusting oh yeah on the side you want
to you want to you want to get involved
that middle hitter looks a little bad to
me that's that alvin kamara if you see
Alvin Camaro on the Saints he where's
that gone dude so does uh who's the
rapper little uh nosey little Josie oh
yeah
Josie bird he does lose eros it little
easy with that thing as a grown man you
can't do that bro
unless you're Lenny Kravitz can't pierce
the well or the nose my thing is this
man if you do you can't that's a no-no
it almost looks like something you would
get it at Spencer's gifts percent and
then he pierced the middle yeah that's
crazy
that boy has depression but that's brave
also that is brave well little Peter
[ __ ] killed himself memory ate all
those pills that guy oh that's right oh
dude oh yeah bro I got ya look at him I
think depression next yeah yeah well
it's different man it's a different time
the middle and I don't know I think if
you you know and he said on girls if
maybe if they kept my extra house you
know key or something on that sucker in
case you got locked out and I could see
some use to it that make sense you know
I feel like you'd look good with a just
a button like that right there dude
I feel like you'd pull so many more hoes
and do whatever you like really just put
that earring right there earring in my
nose yeah you look dope with that dude
that's the other big nose there would be
a big earring dude it probably will I
got a quarter pound away down the left
side of my head though just cut out a
penny just put a penny now that might be
cool if you have like your penny loafers
but it becomes your nose and people put
on nickels in their nose
I say it's a case-by-case basis but it
does it is when I see when I see a woman
with that if you know it does make me
think that she's a brave lady and it
makes me feel like well if she'll stick
something through her nose it you know
she might at least let me take her out
to eat or something see I say King it
you know say King it I'm Austan say King
because I see that nose ring and I think
risk-taker she's down for that she's
down for that ass play King it Jesus
what else we got where are we
we're here this is our game
Ollie named Ella here we go Sweden
that's a hard name to my gang gang gang
and gang name of a real king the Rat
King at the Steam King I have one
question for you guys
colonization of Mars King it or steam
various what was going on hold on hold
on I had so many questions there's a
full rack of moose horns in the back
it's weird there's our national there's
fires that he's stoking it's not like
this is just your regular [ __ ] this and
that is that's not a fireplace bro is
this Liam Neeson son bro who it this is
very unique he's from Sweden brother
dude no you know he's the bad guy
xxx who smokes all the cigarettes
non-stop that's such a whoo-wee
reference you guys wouldn't [ __ ] know
I remember that guy God look he wants us
to kiddie movies like that this is a
burn barrel he has this very unique it
seems like there's something there I
have a lot of questions and Sweden yeah
right yeah I mean yeah is this Sweden
who knows he sounds Sweden he's from
Sweden okay there you go
defense rests so he wants to basically
living on Mars the colonization of Mars
yeah nah [ __ ] this man not for us look
if Sweden wants to go up there I say you
guys do it good luck you're the guinea
pigs yeah we can't colonize Detroit okay
we can't colonize half of the cities in
America so we're trying to figure out LA
yeah why are we gonna go up to Mars and
complicate things yeah dude I saw God
busting a nut off when I was drew exit
in the tan earlier this morning so we
haven't colonized or
ya know we're a lot to learn here yeah
we got a lot to learn but Mars right now
and also it's red yeah it's red on them
I mean it's red I'm like a chart is that
what you're saying like are you saying
the earth of that giant planet is red
the earth of it
did you take a break so Brendon cannot
figure out a say there are some ideas
can you name it how many planets can you
name
can you yeah can't name that majoring in
PDF I dared this is a good design this P
light remind you of home everybody
drinking in fro well I can't get over my
[ __ ] trouble childhood no good man
yeah it's so much sugar than that thing
is it really I'm just kidding me three
titties hanging down your belly
alright about 18% of a day's sugar no
hold on bro just so you know leave this
you educate your ass real quick I might
know my plan that's what repeat this so
this has 25 grams of sugar is that a lot
Oh hold on hold up 25 grams but in its
one serving so there's three servings so
there's 75 grams of sugar in here Hogman
for these do you look good though bro
keep drinking it man put some ice on it
what kind of what are you a psycho you
put it in a nice Peter lie it on ice
codeine and then get that real scissor
that killing lizard you think I'm not
the most interesting man in the in the
nursery the most intriguing on the
playground he's having a real bad father
and try to help you out and on the
playground I can't drink any more this
[ __ ] in it now dude you're fine I
watched two doughnuts down with this a
little while ago I'm not gonna [ __ ]
make it out of this chair yep died I
want I know you've gotta be Michael Huff
come pick me up man jeongae with them
spinners broke man have a couple lot
lizards in there too cuz we don't he
doesn't have long
I'm any idea long I mean he does finish
to lower my glucose
I need any of them lot lizard to have
insulin needles as well colonization of
Mars
[ __ ] [ __ ] Mars no no no I'm sting you
have diabetes I just have a stroke let's
got a refi tavern and trying to get
through that sentence no we have actual
replay now do you don't know I just did
it bro okay I did it for you
hey that's a true talent man I got does
this have replays yeah dude I need to
slow motion too
I just was pretty good thanks dude it
was good
um but I'm gonna say no I'm gonna say
sing it for me say [ __ ] no Wow thinking
it is alright
well I'm a big fan what's up boys daddy
match fan
I'm wrote you this song for the King and
the sting a beautiful skimping that you
like it enough to use it James in his
own
[Music]
yeah I know
Octavia Spencer bro hitting them on tape
all right Celine Dion in this [ __ ] on
the beach dude how is that not the
official song how is that not our
official intro I mean we got to decide
it's king of that's it bro Maddi man
that is it shout out to Maddie Mac will
see conscious at Maddy Mac NJ on on
social dude that's it well so much
better than that other one first of all
I felt like it were not I'll say this is
this gentleman seemed like a nice young
guy a lot of effort into it seemed like
an adult college kid probably played
soccer it looks like his you know short
arms but there's a athletic you look a
definite played soccer his shirt on it
says science so you know he knows his
science well he believes in science so
that's a good rank one dude I think you
changed the theme song to that next week
see how ghosts really yeah it's such a
fun tune let's hear one more time is
that ok can ya know from the rapping was
fun the whole thing was always it is
cool thank you very much Matthew for the
king of the sting and hoping that you
like it enough to use it
we have just the audio though yeah we
grab it easy
he's off sleepers is he yeah bro could
it be sunburned the Italian
[Music]
Prince of Persia baby this thing better
get that cannon and bring you just teed
up bring another bottle
this is [ __ ] vibro yeah he's got a
little Bill Cosby and yeah it does broke
ah dude that's it bro it grows on you I
love it
I think Rose hearing King King oh let's
try it next week bro see how it goes
maybe the fans of dig it you know what
I'm open to a new experience I'm willing
to try it next week I'll say this he
brought all that equipment out there to
the beach I mean you guys can't see it
on the audio only but this gentleman out
at the beach or he just has a bunch of
sand is in an area that might be his
backyard you know what he might be like
the the legit Prince of Persia yeah
that's his bad dog that's his house it's
a backyard that's true cuz sand is just
grass over there you're right and so he
might just have yeah it might not be at
the beach but it's outdoors and his
friends all live behind him like you had
that built on his backyard he probably
has his own Cemetery if you want to for
sure and I bet that if he I just
expected a few more bars he's out at the
beach you got the equipment out there no
I keep it simple man you don't want it
too long you don't need that 3-minute
intro he just hit that god I love this
dude catching our big king you dug all
right i'll King it man nice shot yeah
daddy Mac and Jay but the buzzers mean
no well I'm just doing that yeah okay
well then mine will just be though yeah
yours is no yeah all right word all
right what else we got you guys ready
for a blonde my aunt yeah yeah all these
bad [ __ ] all right this first one we
just got in doggy we coming out ah the
gate Jonathan trow LTX you sense it you
gotta control
Jonathan trolls Wow damn bro real-life
chick Mod Squad hang it huh yeah yeah
bro I'm not mad at the he's flaunting uh
wait is that it that's all is that a
female no fault my heart bro well no you
can't flatten anyone though we call it
the segment flat my own blanket said
that might be flopping my nephew I don't
know that ain't a nephew do that's an
adult man is that an adult it looks like
it's an aunt well you can't be a I mean
I guess you could be a fourteen-year-old
you know a child on you could how is
that another show child on I know Chris
Hansen it's a gig um yeah he does dude
[ __ ] ha this is tough because I like the
style I like the glasses you're seeing
the guys are a little googly whatever
you're seeing a nurse Sally Jessy
Raphael is that what she looks like this
hair first you have a TV grown up so
you've no idea I'm talking about when
you draw for you let me draw up for you
like you were a kid yeah I remember her
from Chicago together I'll say this she
does have that very outdoorsy kind of
groundhog kind of look she was a human
squirrel first of all why is there zero
distance between her her hair white hair
also you know back then and ever
there's no highlights that's her natural
[ __ ] it's all gray down the side and
then can you see march from here like
[ __ ] coke cans son those are sick as
her glasses brother no they're not and
yet telescope well first of all the
glasses aren't even over her eyes that's
a weird thing they're way too is gonna
hit him and they're gonna burn holes in
her cheeks I don't even know if she's
getting any benefit the other that her
side of the glass does she a college
science project fourth graders drawing
himself a Jesse Raphael she weighs over
three or four ounces otherwise they're
gonna start injecting lipstick and
hairspray into her and using her at a
testing facility for Johnson & Johnson
what I'm saying is she does have a very
small
and you know something you would eat at
Thanksgiving but maybe like a native
like kind of the Native American time
when they would have you know squid or
whatever it is or a little bird what is
that little bird squab squab squab she's
got a bird or not you I don't know if
she has birds living in her hair there
is a baffling amount of zero space
between her nose and eyes very huge
amount of hair guys and the glasses are
just like this rocking yeah and the hair
is like she has to be worried that he's
gonna grow over eyes you know oh yeah
soon brother very common Louis tomorrow
Oh a strong wind from the south she'll
never see again the problems you say she
eats alone and TV dinners at night and
she likes [ __ ] night here's
tough-looking she has a lot of friends
and they probably read books or go to
the library it's like she had the best
Trapper Keeper in this school that's
what she looks like she looks like like
she's organized too you know I'm saying
yeah that's true 100% OCD has her notes
with her at all times and she was the
girl with all the pencils and pens in
school yeah we knew if you ran out you
could hit up that girl yeah that's what
she looks like
no scissors bro no sir yeah yeah yes the
sign notice scissors yes to science what
else we got long hair beautiful life
yeah I like her all right here we go
[ __ ] dope man she does she's a unique
looking human I heard that now if this
was Madame black yup like oh well that's
an alien clearly yeah no I'm saying yeah
I would love to see a picture of her now
oh yeah oh yeah me too
be cool we didn't send it in seemed like
a nice lady all right this one's from
Jim dude he brought two aunts Connie and
Tina ooh I'll take that Tina doing this
is honor that young hitter on the left
you talking about the the Pat character
on the right
Tina is on the right I think yeah and
she's getting some Sun you can see a
little bit of Sun hitting her face not
too much water though [ __ ] it was little
golden feel like a drink up you lie bro
it's starting to feel like my head is
turning feels swollen it looks it does a
little bit
I thought you had that pedialite brain I
guess I can't believe this [ __ ] two kids
man is [ __ ] up yeah now you know dude
it's not for adults kids it helps them
it also makes you stupider
don't say that did it may not be true I
had no joke I bought for these last time
this is the fourth one this is all why
would you do that I like it did you tell
your parole officer about the sponsor
you had a parole officer given prison
dude I don't know what you did in the
past man [ __ ] here cut my neighbor brown
neighbor bro somebody flushed this guy
I can't we guys Connie or Tina dude dude
I like both look at having a nice
conversation
I like the aunt on the right kind of has
her titties out you know I'm saying like
little flaunt my tits a little bit there
yeah yeah but also get him out of my
face I'm trying to enjoy my summer salad
yeah don't bunt duck debt which name
hunt flaunt me Tina Tina he's the one in
the green she doesn't look like a teen I
don't want you to bug her jugs that's
what it looks like dude she wants you to
freak trying to get motorboat yeah she
wants to eat macaroni salad a sucker
tits
I wouldn't motorboat him but I might see
do past them [ __ ] you feel me Connie
and Tina are also both nicknames for
drugs so I think this whole city knows
huh
what's a Tina Tina is like a little a
little bit of coke they used to call it
if you got a Tina oh you met Tina yeah
you ain't in it what's a what's a Steven
Steven is a buddy of mine who actually
passed away his brothers name's Steven
and then what so what's a girl what's
the lady on the left Connie what's up
what's a Connie in the drug world I
don't know but it sounds like something
give me a couple condoms right you know
about to [ __ ] me three Connie's in a
Dave on the side yeah yeah give me a
[ __ ] out so that Larry breath you
feel me yeah most people either just go
or drugs his name is Jim dude that's
what I'm saying
Jim dude Jim dude yeah man I'll take
five Ben honeydicked that's two regular
ants I'll take two [ __ ] grams of that
Michael huff you feel me they both
wearing them cardigans this is clearly a
freakin
Colorado what else we got what else we
got don't send your normal Ashley can't
do that there were nice people yes
answer one answer Oh what am we rocket
trip Baby Baby Bear Allison
wow she seems like she she seems like a
nice lady has a dumper honor because we
could rotate this thing she looks like
she has that video vixen dumper yeah but
why don't we just talk about how nice
she looks and what about this year's on
a little petticoat dude that looks like
a nice leather jacket she gets the tits
perked up in the front bring her back -
tits - eyes my eyes very nice lady a
very nice smile now what's going on in
the background this is clearly one of
those photo shoots at the mall you know
somehow they talked her into taking this
picture and a dangerous mall at that
seems to be bullet holes in the wall
behind her now there seems to be some do
to the left who was cut out when she
clearly didn't want in the picture which
I approve of that's probably her ex I
bet yeah for sure but she is flaunting
that she's a beautiful lady she looked
like she might be african-american and
Nate may be Native American - she has
like a strong cheekbones might be Tongan
yeah maybe a drop of Cherokee Indian in
her yeah she got that [ __ ] tongue
inside hit his brother yeah she Tongans
have a [ __ ] chin bone on she got that
damn brontosaurus they do then she gets
that tomahawk booty oh yeah brah oh yeah
she got that real sharp but what else
she's in shape dude this is the best
we've ever had that somebody's at
someone's at goddamn what's-her-name and
Alison Danni I was sayin Alison she also
looks like she started off as a
receptionist but she's working her way
up you know and she's almost - that may
be gonna be the head of a company so you
know just start her own because she
looks like she'll sell you some spinners
now oh yes she does she look like she's
sell you some spinners
are you into uh you do you like like
girls you like chocolate drip um yeah
Louisiana you would it be I mean I would
I probably had a different experience
like they didn't have like a lot like
like black girl beat me
up during volleyball when I was young
why oh [ __ ] you know game she was
violent but yeah I was pretty bad I was
that volleyball or tetherball because I
feel like she'd be too shy in tetherball
no she beat me up just during the game
volleyball but um I actually I looked up
with a black girl out here a couple
years ago about nine years ago and it
was very I wasn't I was it wasn't always
your to light in the ass I feel like
because you have a flat ass and most of
them don't I got that hitter bro are you
talking about there I got a couple of
[ __ ] deaf yard boys under my [ __ ]
pants make up a flapjack
yeah what dude dude I have the ass of a
Down syndrome kid man mm-hmm yeah you
haven't seen it that you know a lot of
you know apparently you don't have a lot
of friends in yoga pants the anal health
issues then like I do know but beautiful
lady on our on Allison hottest woman
we've had yet shoutout to Alice an
awesome one last one from Brandon Risto
grandma Lorna and I guess her nicknames
horny warning all my favorite things in
it
Winnie the Pooh which I actually really
do like dude you like where the poo
where's my tail oh yeah he going this
name it's your your yeah but I like the
Hundred Acre Wood bro you know I'm
saying a lot of [ __ ] out there and
then a hundred-acre dude and once I say
plan to reel in some honey honey so yeah
she's flaunting that sexy pink
sweatshirt she got that a little bit of
neck hang you could you read my drift
she's got that you know she got that
gullet bro that turkey gobbling gobble
gobble baby now she likes a little bit
of like a little bit of John Goodman in
her right a little bit of a John Goodman
fine she got that John go he looks like
Jeff Ross a little bit late she's on
Roseanne's couch right now
they just chilling please she smoked
weed for the first time on the set of
Roseanne yeah she does she uh yeah man
she really does I feel like look like
that neck said now let's go all the way
down
that neck is trying to [ __ ] take her
face up and I like that like that at
least like the softest skin in the world
that's that sex neck dude that [ __ ] you
open up like God you just grab it like a
peerless sail borrow that [ __ ] is so
soft
that's a softest skin in the world you
felt your grandma's fat ass neck that
turkey gobbler there's not softer skin
in the world cat is offended right now
well they can't date them my grandma has
nine chin yes you really nine chin Wow
yes that's unbelievable
yeah it's pretty cool and it's the
softest skin of all time I go for a hug
and make sure I put my fingers through
the chapters of her neck that's pretty
good man dude man I think all that
sugars giving me a damn headache yeah
you kind of fell off bro I mean it's
called the 1-800 number on that you look
like you ate some bad bears on your Boy
Scout trip and it's doing well yeah I've
had probably almost 2,000 grams of sugar
rush I had a lot dude had this doughnut
so I'd won them doughnuts I feel great
in that aunt with her fat ass neck aunt
looks like sheets 12 dudes a day oh
right
whatever alone bro I'm gonna say this
you seem like a woman that spends time
at the YMCA she's very active
she probably runs she wears group she
looks pretty active you think maybe not
I feel like she does nothing but read
and give it and give advice to everybody
on the relationships like she likes to
be the one all up in the relationships
that's what she looks like and gives
tarawa in but she's single it's never
worked out for her she got that spicy
headpiece though man she's wearing you
can't see her in the audio she has on a
trucker hat to the side like she's
flavorful is paid yeah David Spade dude
how about the title says grandma Lorna
horny horny horny horny horny horny so
she throws that [ __ ] jerk dude should
get that
chirp-chirp cricket neck on your day rub
it right baby
cricket rub it right like you deciding
to talk is just like somebody who just
starts falling downhill and they have no
idea
yeah it's on is that it for this June
shut up the horny horny horny Lauren
about to take that bust off of me
you guys ready for debate club oh [ __ ] I
forgot we had to bake yeah let's do it
it feels about the pass out from all the
Pedialyte do my children close my eyes
are keep close your face starting to
swell up like it stung huh welcome to
the club bro let's see what I do I see
what I deal with every day
no no man you got that venom in that
system I need that grandma chin alright
what are the first ones from John knee
Macross Kowski polish prior you [ __ ]
savages no debate club grant I don't
know I know no happy gilmore or Billy
Madison why is he up DBD still debate
that which one of those [ __ ] is
funny mm-hmm what's up John Moscow ski
thank you for sending it in and that
videos not creepy at all is he on the
dark web and then sent this dark um
happy gilmore Billy Madison two of my
all-time favorites Adam saying was my
favorite growing up as a kid I can
easily see that ya seem like a guy you
like he's funny yeah I love him I'm
happy yeah I don't know this one's tough
ah Billy Madsen I did cuz it reminds me
of Steel because he had to go back
through school it did like do it his way
basically was homeschooled and then had
to go back he failed all the grade so I
love that it's Billy Madison that's
Billy Madison n that's the Billy Madison
the Veronica Vaughn I don't think I've
seen Billy Madison but I have seen what
the other one what you never seen Billy
Madison
I don't think so telling about what we
were raised in a cave never seen Billy
Madison oh you'd have electric art man
that makes sense
you know we had electricity we I
remember the movie we watched growing up
curly sue have you ever seen that yeah
you from the sixties
no I haven't seen that bro it's a great
you've never seen happy gilmore I have
seen of your Ma Barker pizzas ass and
you know who else isn't happy killer
Will Sasso makes it yeah yeah oh wow
really see you up in the beginning this
was too tougher to call if I had to pick
really Madison baby
really something cuz I'd like about a
spoiled kid what is it yeah that's
exactly what a spoiled kid let's go back
to school and he starts at grade one
works his way up to get his dad's
company back to school back to school
I think the rich get too many second
opportunities man so I'm gonna go with
the other one happy gilmore some guy
remembers he golf and he's down on his
luck I think his parents from pedophiles
or something and then he got you know
got the clubs and got out of the house
and changed his life nah man he's trying
to save his grandma's house bro yes yeah
I'm Ben Stiller's innit
I like that much better give you a warm
glass shut the hell up you can go to
sleep I'll put you to sleep I'll take a
one glass of anything other than
Pedialyte no Joe Pedialyte is warm
that's all problem but I feel sugar
starting to crystallize Bahama dude
let's go about taffy any second all
right this is from Jacob I chopped up
some cotton ky say uh no we don't use
that for now Oh God P lights really glad
you put your buzzer down bro
god damn it man no babies are gonna hit
you oh my it's me this that's why it's
for just babies dude I feel like my arms
feel weird
yeah they look hairy they do mm-hmm
thanks man fans say a whopping 70% for
happy gilmore and so what we're doing is
every week now for debate club we're
putting on our Instagram story so you
guys can vote and tell us who you think
so you want to apologize to the fans you
got it wrong you well I still think well
do the fans [ __ ] think happy gilmore
I still think Billy Madison so well well
so I gonna got it wrong I guess what
else we got all right this is from Jay
cweigand shop Theo what's up Brendan I'm
Jake I'm from Rochester New York
I got a debate club for you guys in a
street fight LeBron James versus Floyd
Mayweather let's go
LeBron James versus Floyd Mayweather
first I've seen Floyd in person shoutout
Rochester son brother we
my favorite radio station my boy Baggins
used to be a rapper up there he died he
overdosed but here this here this
doesn't matter
he's pretty decent rapper and nice guy
I'll say this
Floyd Mayweather LeBron James first of
all is the tight end is the NFL's best
hiding that they allowed to play in the
NBA career because he was too soft to
get hit in the NFL mm-hmm so I'm gonna
go with Floyd Mayweather all day Floyd
is such a more skilled boxer yeah I mean
I the Broncos baby powder in the air
that's his finishing move Floyd probably
[ __ ] Mach schnell
even though LeBron's huge in he's he's
been spoon-fed his entire life so he's
not gonna be very tough Boyd price still
[ __ ] him up I'll take Floyd all right
what's the fan say LeBron James 59% Wow
Floyd me with a 40 100 all of our fans
live in Cleveland that's right so I
apologize to the fans what else all
right we got Jeff Henderson sup boys
coming live from Tokyo I'll be thinking
is that guy Japanese no I'm not I'm from
Vancouver originally big fan of you guys
anyways debate topic The Sopranos versus
any other TV show ever
thoughts random definitely a male pop
your thought that who thinks Pedialyte
and hangs out at playgrounds oh your kid
thought I spend time outdoors but yeah
it looks like you're him oh yeah apart
from the Garth Brooks let's see here
dude I've never seen Sopranos oh wow
what do you mean wow do you even know
what happy gilmore was yeah Sopranos
have you guys have you I've seen a
couple episodes of Sopranos people say
it's the best show ever next to the wire
I've seen the wire why was good little
long season three was long right I don't
know soprano so I can't really check
honesty do you one loves Sopranos in
here yes from New Jersey so if you suck
Sopranos off people love it they say
it's like the best like Mafia show ever
and the head boss like it tells the
story through the therapist right they
came in the
hissing sound like like he's a regular
dude she was like his daily life and
stuff like that I don't know I've never
seen it I definitely need to watch it
I prefer some shows I like in the heat
of the night you remember that show it's
on reruns now as that was Bruce Willis
no it had detective Virgil Tibbs in it I
don't know who played I'm not I don't
know that oh no you're talking of Miami
Vice it's so good bro it's not a movie
you creep
is it television I know Boyd Carroll
O'Connor is buried over there and right
near my house where I live at mmm near
the apartment but I'll say this
the man Dateline first of all people say
Sopranos there's a lot of murders in it
Dateline you ever seen this show called
Dateline every episode somebody gets
murdered but one of the best shows I've
ever seen probably Dateline Dateline NBC
or Dateline oh you're talking about the
news yeah yeah people die all the time
on the show so if you like murder
mystery I like that more than something
like I've never seen this show because
because it looks terrible [ __ ] so
it's awful and also I'm not 70 years old
I don't hang out my grandma in her frog
down and watch this [ __ ] show you are
so limited you are it's all that you had
on TV honey but moms VHS cassettes of
this just watched every episode over and
over and these are your heroes
I'm nervous yeah that's his son that's
it's just some of the left and he died
here I haven't seen an app one episode
of Sopranos but I can guarantee it's
better than that so I'm gonna say
Sopranos for sure what about I'll tell
you something in what about just the ten
of us from that show sure haven't a lot
of hot chicks bring it up brother
dude you're seeing step by step no I
don't watch that kind of stuff oh my god
you're seeing step by step look at that
day by day's deal brother
dude that's a porno bro that's a porno
bro hey see you can compete you like
watching this [ __ ] dude I'm no detective
but this is an easy case to solve
look at that [ __ ] dude go to step by
step day by day minute by minute you
don't know that [ __ ] what Sesame
no bro step-by-step it would go step by
step with a hot-ass mom yeah look at
that time he died Suzanne Somers yeah
bro well I did an informer formed it a
pyramid scheme one time that she was at
- I didn't realize really yeah I got
there it took my mom back I went out
performed then she went up right after
me and she holler at her all these
vitamins no and then I went around front
to look and see what was going on I was
like oh people cheer from vitamin yeah
dude remember she has a ThighMaster
she'd do that thing them in them and
them tight on Jack after as a kid at
night Ryan oh I think I do remember
yeah that's early 90s - bro beautiful
adult lady mm-hmm beautiful she had a
ThighMaster all right you can use that
[ __ ] right now I'm gonna say this I
probably could use something to get this
but a little down I need to untie me
though you need me more no yeah you just
need some meat back there bro buta peril
you don't know how to look at another
man's ass brother because now I see
yours when you walk that thought and
there's a flat ass what there's no power
back - how do you even walk no how do
you if there's a gust of one how do you
walk into the wind he's gotta go wit the
way only head east I can only go eat
yeah he's gotten he has no left hand
guys they don't like I've never seen
Sopranos but I know it's better than any
TV show Theo just mentioned and probably
out and step by step any show ever
that's a [ __ ] Wow most people gave it to
that they gave it to us huh yep
60 personally just our Voting comes from
Iraq so that's cool and what else we got
here you go you guys like this one
Cassandra McGee damn McGee or cats love
the podcast and keep doing what you do
it super seems like a really nice person
yeah chin has a full boner right now did
you see his face goes yeah super hot I
just saw the blood leave his [ __ ]
face and neck and head down south right
to help a real white body
right yeah um yeah she's a dime piece
thanks for listening Cassandra McGee
dogs all [ __ ] day if you say
cats we cannot be friends steal you cat
cats [ __ ] sucked
cats don't need anybody can leave cats
and you just get they don't trust
anybody you just leaving water and food
and dip out and they don't give up [ __ ]
dogs every time coming it's like the
superball it's like you're the MVP every
day when you walked in that huh really
yeah I never had a dog I think cats you
know you grow up with cat I got attacked
by two cats when I was young and I got
attacked by two dogs on my birthday one
year not a dog bite my ass when I was a
kid you did it be right in the ass mmm I
still up and I still love him I still
love him but cats like you leave cats
five or six days you come back they
don't care if you were gone or if you're
there they don't even notice
so like shitty parents dude that's what
I feel like I agree so I'm gonna go with
dogs dogs all day what kind of voting we
got here better be dogs and she has nice
dogs so I need someone to watch your
dogs let me know girl mm-hmm all right
the voting is 87 yeah I saw yeah yeah
get rid of cash bro don't [ __ ] touch
me cat lover what else we got all right
Josh isbister what up the L what up
Brennan Josh here reporting in from
Prince Albert Saskatchewan Canada
screaming debate DJs or live bands their
Dogma in the back of his head right now
it's a little weird is if peanut butter
on the back of his neck it's Canada bro
no it's not I've been in Canada they
don't do that weird [ __ ] it's called the
car you live in a green room bro that's
called the Canadian [ __ ] tourniquet
bro you put a little peanut butter on
the back in neck and let the dog lick it
off it's called Canadian massage
question was live bands or DJ's [ __ ]
live band DJ's oh look here's my iPad
everyone's having a good time playlist
hit play that'll get drugs yeah yeah go
get drugs go [ __ ] girls roofies
that's what they do bro can't trust a DJ
can't trust a DJ if you want to be the
biggest DJ in the world and you
committed to it next year you could be
[ __ ] hosting MTV Spring Break yeah
you could do that my band my van
come I like a lot bankers you could get
hit you know you're there next you know
you somebody gets hit in the head your
date gets hit in the head with a damn
drumstick that the guy threw out yes or
the pick from the guitar just boom [ __ ]
right in the eye you can't repeat that
kind of you know you don't get that at a
DJ you know what's he gonna throw into
the end of the crowd is medium shirt
roofies
yeah roofies so very limited style with
DJ this one's so easy I feel like [ __ ]
yeah DJ scare people a lot a lot of them
died that one guy died oh they do a lot
of drugs you know you have to do drugs
to be a DJ yeah it's like part of the
gig you have to lift weights to be a
football player you gotta do drugs to be
a DJ so I'm gonna say no then I'm gonna
say a hard note live band let me say
live bands brother but the Beatles live
band 80% live bands oh yeah how are your
CV percent still take indeed 20% you're
seeing train in person now they're good
dude I've seen goo goo dolls no joke
five times dude they're great his
haircuts totally disturbing they're
great
what the little drummer the guitarist
the lead guitarist no undenied looks
like a penguin though bring that man up
that beautiful you know I don't think
they sing like that
Oh Clint Eastwood's the lead singer of
Goo Goo Dolls no spicy spicy Larry nah
do check out the highlights on the likud
on the left areas the lead singers had a
bunch of face work huh oh yeah
definitely
damn bro you look like Spencer's threw
up on them yeah they're like Spencer's
yeah they look they look like they're
sponsored by Spanish that's a wild man
all right is that it we got one last one
- you guys ready for the-- literally
it's worth it
it's j-rod all this is does yeah hey Mon
boy
[Applause]
[Music]
but I'm not sure which was better to use
tail or tissue you know I just can't
decide right now guys about getting
awesome
made my week that's j-rod I love that
dude but talented I'm super talented
I think he's we're gonna avatar - so
this is an easy one for me right here so
you throw a curveball at it how or
tissue
neither sock I grab that old sock that
old Nike sock maybe doesn't fit in with
the rest of them I grab that I put my
hand like a hand puppet so it doesn't
get any on my hand and then I go I do
that snakey sneaking along my body what
do you use what do you whatever you were
just doing please
children's blanket first effusions party
supplies yes I don't come anymore bro so
if I'm looking up with a girl or
anything even I don't come I just stop
before I'm gonna come and I just go home
is that what your pee hotels you do huh
now put your pee oh so it's not a parole
officer you can't bust nuts your Pio
doesn't let you belts nuts I'm not
busting a frickin nut over for it
something for some girl that barely even
know dude what about the Internet what
about dudes
um know also so I would say this towel
or tissue first of all a sock is just a
towel shaped like a foot you [ __ ] man
why don't you realize that yeah but you
can put it on ma'am let him put it on
your hand and then just [ __ ] it's
like a talking puppet that cleaned it up
and then when you're here up it to clean
up there see brother but also as a kid
your parents like that's just a sock on
the floor super-crispy price sweating
and everything but if you have a towel
they know what's up baby
they know what's up using a ton of
tissues they know what's up sock they
don't know what the [ __ ] happening and
you got to mix it up maybe it's both
socks don't you
black socks has to be white socks here
you don't know [ __ ] bro you don't know
[ __ ] you just come down the walls at
your house Oh your mom thought it was
candles dude but now that you bring out
candles I will say this a lot of guys
didn't have a camera by the bed will
skied out into that candle dude you know
what the best thing is you're the best
idea you've ever come up with bust into
those lava lamps yeah [ __ ] a sock
[ __ ] towel
jackoff in the lava lamp yet now you got
entertainment why don't we make those
yeah see monkey lava lands yeah yeah see
monkey semen key semen monkeys we got to
work on the title see where ya reach
halfway there dude I think you know that
yeah I think Robin nut lamp no nope and
then we're gonna keep thinking about the
title but uh but the thing is I made my
week though Oh Jay Raj but I know this
definitely not tissues don't be an
[ __ ] save the environment man a towel
you can reuse can wash you know
yeah washing kills the environment
though no the environments gonna die so
that's why we gotta mark do our best
you know that ain't that's my homeboy
wants to go to Mars yeah full circle
look full circle yeah go to Mars we're
gonna die immediately dude stay here you
might die I'm just gonna go with homeboy
in the truck and jacked off in the
towels dude look I I used to do the
thing sometimes that even put out like a
beach towel a nice big beach talent
jerk-off on to that or like I don't like
having to clean it all up so my thing
ever jacked off in a hotel and just roll
in the sheets no me neither
never done that me neither ever and I
don't even like jerking off anymore man
so I'm trying not to do it
your video says no to that yeah well
yeah I'm down I like I mean exercise
your Duff semi recently but not that
recently but anyhow towel man I can't
really even keep my eyes open to towel
let's go tell them to get the other part
Wow on what happen has yeah shoot
tissues goddamn who's using Kleenex like
a psycho yeah somebody's doing paper
mache God who is it maybe that's what
they're doing with Boston in it and then
making like figures out of it oh I could
see that yeah me sense it is crazy how
much semen goes to waste every day in
America we think about how many loads
are dropped right
now millions upon millions not thinking
about that at all I was thinking about
other normal stuff like what I need to
do later today well no you just said
think about it yeah just think about how
much is wasted
I don't think about how many are hitting
the [ __ ] floorboards right now floor
boom Savage what are you a pirate
floorboards you're on a ship journey on
a jack off I'm gonna make a flower
brother
alright let's get you out of it for you
die and we don't want to get that money
kid he's gotta get my legs above my
heart taking in the sting he'll be all
right I'll keep you guys posted
somebody caught this is mine it's not
liver right now
ginger sting it feel dying cuz he do it
sugar
[Applause]
[Music]